ayrault c'est youssef qui est devenu le
héros lors de l'attaqué devant les
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo le 25
septembre
oui ouseph s'il vous plaît merci 7
en plus j'ai l'impression qu'on se
connaît bah on se connaît mais si ça on
se connaît bah oui un moment comme et
oui c'est ça
c'est tout ça on se connaît et j'ai vu
j'ai dû me nous sommes je le connais
très bien satan qui franchement merci
d'être là je peux je suis fier de toi et
merci pour l'invitation ses relais et ce
matin il ya eu celle qui vient gmail
youtube je connais très bien merci
youssef c'est un héros c'était le 25
septembre dernier
exactement youssef voilà c'est vous
décidé d'intervenir le 25 septembre
dernier puisque vous êtes à côté des
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo et vous
voyez ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe le 25 septembre raconté bas
j'étais là à côté de l'immeuble de 53 à
la monture micro déshabille toi toi je
te tutoie parce qu'on se connaît
voilà on se connaît ok bah j'étais là
dedans à côté de l'immeuble de ses
comptes roi richard lenoir
bien sûr il ya un moment donné j'étais
dans la voiture et j'ai entendu des cris
d'une femme qui a crié après un moment
donné il y avait un nombre qui a crié
qui a dû aussi non non j'ai dit qu'est
ce qui se passe je sors de la voiture je
vois un gars qui dirige vers halak la
bouche de métro avec un hachoir plein de
sons et à ce moment là moi j'ai dit
croire comment ça se fait je crois
c'était un vol ou bien c'est une
agression et comment ça se fait en vas
tu voles mta grèce la personne vous lui
parlez vous avez parlé à la personne non
si c'était après que j'ai parlé avec
personne c'était j'ai pensé ça j'ai dit
ah vous voyez une personne avec un
hachoir
ouais plein de sons et j'ai dit quoi
j'ai réagi sans réfléchir du coup j'ai
poursuivi la personne j'ai essayé de
l'attraper pour livrer à la police
et moi ce que j'ai fait en fait j'ai
quand j'ai poursuivi moi j'ai descendu
l'escalier qui s'était à droite sauter
le portique d'abord est descendu à
droite les escaliers qui s'était à
droite cherchait sur les quais je n'ai
pas trouvé et je le vois enfin je dis
que tu restes lavage surmonter je suis
remonté pour descendre des autres
escaliers et à ce moment là j'arrive à
lui il me sera testé un cutter ou bien
c'était un couteau
du coup il me sort un cutter je dis
qu'est ce que tu as fait et à ce moment
là il m'a parlé avec ils l'ont que je
comprenais pas et il a fait deux pas en
arrière il est rentré dans le métro et
je suis remonté et quand je suis remonté
pour voir s'il y avait des caméras ou
quoi que ce soit
et à ce moment là je mentais j'ai essayé
d'appeler la police
et il y avait un monsieur qui arrivent
et gilles m'a dit il est où le mec je
dis vous n'allez pas l'attraper vous
allez l'aapei léa est parti vers la
bastille il y avait la police qui
concerne est interpellé vous faites
comment vous avez interpellé ce qu'ils
vous ont pris je crois pour en fait
n'est pas vous avez été interpellé par
la police
donc voilà après après c'est ça juste
après en fait parce qu'un sac voilà
juste après en fait quand et la police
sont arrivés ils voulaient suivre la
personne je leur ai dit ça sert à rien
de suivre vous allez vers là-bas si vous
allez l'attraper et jeudi à son assureur
qui l'a laissée ici là vous allez
retrouver ses empreintes et tout est à
ce moment là à ce moment là il y avait
une autre voiture de policiers arrivés
et ils ont fait il voulait faire la même
chose et je leur ai dit pareil j'aurais
dit vous allez l'attraper vers là-bas c
est tout et moi je voulais aller pour
voir qu'est ce qu'il a fait exactement
la personne et je vois un victimes qui
étaient là au sol plein de sang et tout
et il y avait un policier qui venu me
voir et m'a dit je dégage d'ici jeudi
comment ça se fait je vais dégager alors
que moi je suis juste pour vous dire en
fait moi je suis la personne
du coup il m'a dit est ce que vous avez
des papiers sur vous je dise les
patients moi je suis reparti dans le
besoin pour récupérer mes papiers et à
ce moment là quand je suis récupérer ma
papier il ya mon petit frère qui
m'appellent et me disait il faut que tu
reviens parce qu'à la police qui
quittent eux cherchent et comment ça se
fait en fait moi voilà je gare ma
voiture vers le boulevard de richard
lenoir et à ce moment là je suis parti
pour voir la police et j'ai demandé à
des policiers de loreidy en fait moi je
suis juste pour porter moynier m'a dit
est ce que vous avez votre ps dit tenter
de faire bouger dit ouais je suis là
elle est là du coup il a appelé son et
l'appeler sans franchement chef et à
essentielle qui est arrivé il a vu en
fait sur son téléphone il a vu que
c'était la même personne qui a vu sur
les pieds du coup à ce moment là ils
m'ont pris vers vers le quidam de métro
et à un moment donné ils m'ont posé des
questions et tout est à ce moment là à
ce moment là je leur ai dit je leur
racontais exactement tout ce qui s'est
passé et ils m'ont dit il faut que tu
viens avec nous à au commissariat je
leur ai dit comment ça se fait moi je
suis venu juste pour témoigner je vais
pas venir avec laurent commissariat ils
m'ont dit on est obligé leurs idioties
je vais venir avec la procédure
exactement je leur ai dit a pas de souci
je viens avec vous mais à ce moment là
ils m'ont met les menottes paris voilà
c'est bizarre sinon pris pour un con
qu'il faut fermer les portes il faut pas
leur en vouloir qu'elle sincèrement ils
ont fait grande impression
c'est une pression énorme gérer un prix
j'étais calme
voilà jeté sur moi qui vous ont lâché
ils vous ont dit que quand ils m'ont
lâché féliciter parce que c'est grâce à
vous quand même qu'on a vraiment aidés
ils ont demandé des excuses et où il
mangeait pas combien de temps après on a
fait dix ans après garde à vue procédure
à caractère terroriste et tousser
d'accord on veut comprendre et après
vous ont félicité paul eymond félicité à
un des policiers qui à qui j'ai fait
confiance et c'est lui qui m'a félicité
du coup je suis sorti après depuis je
suis dit qu'est votre statut vous
travaillez oui je travaille en fait on a
une entreprise de btp en familiale du
coup on travaille en france
maintenant je suis né en algérie
d'accord vous faites quoi citoyens
français
bon je suis chute algérien et il se
prend sur nous dans une carte de
résident souvient exactement
vous avez une carte de résident je vais
passer la police à vous dire que vous
êtes un immigré exactement je suis
ingénieur régulière voire l'assesseur
qui travaillent et qui travaillent qui
paient des impôts exactement équipe de
ses 9 ans et qui concerne terroristes et
ça c'est aussi ça l'immigration
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]